hey brad hey jennifer how are you good
thank you okay how are you
i'm great so you need to know child's
play was the very first horror film i
ever saw i have such a special place in
my heart for chucky so i'm so excited
for this series brad what was your
reaction when don came to you saying
that they were going to create this
chucky tv series
very excited and like um well we'll
we'll um we'll know it's real when it's
real but uh so i heard about it and um
and it was like it seemed like a kind of
an uphill climb to to to really finally
i mean a tv series a big thing
and um and it's not something that you
would imagine but then when i thought
about it i thought
you know this would really work i think
we people at this point want to know
more about these characters
and you can you know dive into character
much better in a series than you can in
a single movie
so that's the name that's what i have to
say about that also i think people are
viewing things in a different way like
especially with the pandemic but people
aren't really going to movies as much
anymore and i travel all around the
world and people know chucky everywhere
and what they know it from a lot of
times is from their tv or you know their
bootleg copies
that they watch at home but um i know
don mancini was really excited about the
series because as fred says he has the
opportunity now to explore the
characters that we have eight episodes
so that's like eight are they one hour
wait
yeah
well eight one hour episodes um the
studios have been so kind to us we have
so much money to explore so everything
is first class on this when i stepped
onto the set and i saw the beautiful
cinematography and the beautiful sets
and all the crew and everything i
thought wow it's like we've hit the big
time because you know sometimes with
those chucky movies they would be like
oh you want to make another chucky movie
okay here's 27 cents and we'd be like
okay nobody drink the coffee we need
that money for to pay the adr you know
so it's just been such a pleasure and
the characters are so well written in
this series
absolutely i know as a and and as a fan
it was really fascinating to learn more
about charles lee ray and his back story
brad was that exciting for you too
yeah yeah i am i'm always like i mean
you know obviously i've had my own ideas
but
um um you know i'm always
really
excited to see what don's gonna be doing
with it and um i got the whole script
every time so um i uh
you know i was going yeah
this is okay this is gonna work
yeah i was excited and i know the fans
have been cl clambering for a back story
like there's a lot of fan sites and they
do fan fiction on tiffany and charles
lee ray before they became dolls and i
was always saying to dawn like oh we
have to do maybe we can do like uh you
know flashback seated you know cause i
honestly i wanted to make out with brad
30 years later they do it but obviously
you know we're too old to do the
flashbacks so they bring in bring in the
younger actors to reenact the but the
you know the the backstory but it's
still really interesting to me because i
had no idea tiffany was that blood
thirsty right from the beginning but it
does make sense you know
and it's it's just so in the little the
girl who plays tiffany she actually
looks like me and she is half chinese or
half asian which is what i am also so he
did a really good job casting her
well i have to tell you out of all the
films proud of chucky so one of my
favorite jennifer mine
my favorite of the series thank you
really
yeah i remember i remember after we did
the the read through what not the read
through the recording and i never
recorded before and you know they put
brad in this um us in the same booth
different booths so we could improvise
and he's so good at improvising like we
improvised a lot of some of the funny
bits in the movie but when he would
throw something at me i'll be like right
back at you and at the end of the movie
i looked over in the booth and he was
crying because tiffany dies and i was
crying too and i thought wow it's just
like wonderful to work with this
brilliant actor
and be playing a little plastic doll at
the same time is
such a strange feeling we were up to
astonishingly
naughty things naughty things yes i mean
i was i remember feeling when we had sex
and i i mean when we did it in the booth
it was normal
you know you and me going
like we were having sex but when the
dolls were doing it oh my gosh
well you know when the doll when the
doll was goes to kiss her when chuckie
goes to kiss tiffany i made a gargling
noise like like he was like putting
because then when i saw it they had his
tongue go out it was like rotating in my
mouth
i was like well that's interesting and
yeah you did see like a
doll butt and uh in silhouette you saw
dull penetration we were the first ones
to do it you know south park copied us
with their doll set yeah they caught but
we we were ground groundbreaking in that
regard
this is so true so i have to ask you
know we're talking about dolls here but
you know when you have chucky and you
have tiffany and they're serial killers
and they murder people but we can't get
enough of them we're always rooting for
them why do you think that is brad
well i mean you know you kind of root
for for all the monsters don't you in
some kind of a way
i mean you know
deeply psychological it's probably that
um you know everybody has genes that
have to deal with the fact that they can
be prey and that's what horror films are
all about um
they're all about uh that that feeling
and it's like a roller coaster ride
where you get to experi experience that
but you're safe
um
and um some i mean very early on in in
uh
uh horror there was this series called
uh there was a a show called dr fives
and it was the first really camp horror
movie and it introduced a sense of fun
that has never left um horror and i
think um i think you have to be careful
not to be too funny with this but
but chucky's funny you know i mean
having a little doll i'll be a mean
little monster
there's some humor there yeah
genius so um there's no uh
there's no way around that and and
you know i'm awed by tiffany uh by uh uh
by jennifer's uh ability to improvise i
mean one of the
the movies the blue lagoon
she did one of my favorite speeches of
all time and it was an improvisation and
i just thought it was one of the most
brilliant uh uh scenes uh i've ever seen
so
dancing it dancing at the blue the blue
lagoon and it was the it was the the
speech when you were you know i know the
way where
yeah yeah you were going to get an
abortion and and the lady was picking on
you
yes
from smoking yeah and that that scene
was totally improvised i think the
reason why people love jackie is he's so
unapologetic you know he doesn't his
problem he has problems but he's like a
regular guy like he smokes a doobie and
he yells at his wife and you know he's
got a gender fluid kid he's got to deal
with and you know but he has a good time
he has a good time killing people he's
not like one of those now it seems like
the trend is like uh monsters not
monsters but killers that are really
tortured and you know you see that they
were really sort of abused as a child
and what don wanted to do in this is
when the backstory is to say no it
wasn't like he had a terrible time he
had a great childhood some people are
just born bad and i think that that's a
really interesting thing that he added
to the back story that you know chucky
yeah me too yeah it's it yeah there's
not it's not some deep psychological
glitch
and the same goes for you yeah yeah and
tiffany too like they don't really i
think tiffany has a bit more of a
conscious and um
than chucky but you know killing is just
so darn fun
in some of the other movies she's trying
to do like the 12-step program in like
three days but she's trying to wean
herself she knows
intellectually it's not good to kill but
she really likes to kill so it's very
difficult for her to get rid of her
killing addiction
well her chucky addition addiction is
the worst you know she keeps trying to
kick chucky to the curb but he keeps
coming back
yeah that takes that addiction is the
strongest yeah
well i just said you guys are both so
entertaining to talk to i've watched the
first four episodes and i'm hooked they
only gave us four so i can't wait to
finish it well it goes totally bonkers
the fifth episode that's when i come in
and all the og's uh fiona dora who plays
nica brad's daughter comes in and andy
barkley comes back and kyle christine
elise comes back so it gets cr
hazy you're gonna love the last four the
first four is brilliant too but
that's always insane thanks
thanks nice talking thank you so much
you guys bye
you